Countries around the world are
struggling with what to do about
cryptocurrencies. Some countries want to
encourage them, others want to control
them, and others want them to just go
away. What are the concerns? Well, the UK
worries about price volatility and
criminal use. US regulators are talking
about fraud, unregulated activities, and
price bubbles. What appears to underlie
the push for regulation is a fear that
cryptocurrencies cannot be easily
controlled; that they may have impacts
that we can't foresee. The fears are
well-founded: Cryptocurrencies are
really just lines to computer code that
can be as variable as coders'
imaginations, and those pieces of code
are spread across computers around the
world. Yet, this is the future of digital
markets: People will be engaging in
economic relationships that are varied
and ever-changing. This is a difficult
future for government regulatory systems.
They're used to regulating things like
bank accounts and stocks where
specialized rules and organizations can
be set up. Cryptocurrencies could
disrupt this historical approach to
regulation.
Do you think cryptocurrency should be regulated? If so, how?
Let us know your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.